[Music]
hey welcome patreon people back to
[ __ ] up news the show that has real
[ __ ] up news sometimes and sometimes
weird news today best intro this guy's
good right i'm ringing off the
teleprompter uh today we're talking
about chinese parents putting molds on
their babies heads so that they grow
rounder what oh are they [ __ ] cone
shaping them with the elongated skulling
them kind of i feel like this is old bro
i don't feel like they do
your skull isn't forming correctly they
have those helmets you have helmets but
they don't look like this though this is
you kind of look like that kind of look
like that this is covering the whole
head the most [ __ ] up thing is like
people who were born like i think in our
age that were like chinese you'll see a
lot of flat-headed [ __ ] chinese kids
oh my god because their parents just
left them without [ __ ] heading to
them and so they would just sleep on
their head the whole time
then you have a flat back yeah that's
why you see you see a lot of these like
[ __ ] chinese the [ __ ] back of
their heads
check out barcelona his square all over
though it's even that's a cranium bar's
got a lego head
it's a cylindrical shape like my mom
bought the wrong one
she put me in amazon
yeah you're a cereal bottle yeah
literally went to your head dude it's
like it's all there she got the cheap
one she wanted to be able to like slide
the other hair and the other kids like
just make him neatly like the square
water tank's ugly and [ __ ] up huh
everyone's got a bart's [ __ ] head is
your korean side dude sorry man yeah so
bad so parents are shelling out for each
parents are showing out for helmets that
they believe can help mold their babies
heads into ideal rounded shapes so what
do they like out there [ __ ] they
definitely don't like cemu lose face
that's for sure
he roasted that phone what did they say
about him he said he was ugly really
yeah super unwarranted dude like the
guy's just chilling in his room he opens
up his [ __ ] ipad he goes simulator's
the ugliest person in china it's like
what the [ __ ] guy but they like
weird-looking [ __ ] they're
aliens bro yeah i think it's because he
has like a like a big face and they like
the really tiny small like no like
texture in your face have you seen those
like those like makeup transformations
where the girls like like do all that
[ __ ] with their like tape their eyes
they were genuinely upset that he got
casted for shang chi because they're
like they're so much better looking
chinese actors just like buddy i looked
this up on quora
is similar the actor playing shane chee
and the new um you know movie handsome
the answer
it says simalu is not considered ugly in
china nor very handsome he is a okay guy
because there are tons of guys who look
like him or have similar looks okay guys
that's absolutely brutal
i think they probably want someone that
looks like chris wu can you look up
chris through with the case see that guy
chris wu looks like a bts guy
chris wu or like he looks very feminine
or something
i think i got k-r-i-s i supposed to like
the crypto sorry okay
k-r-a-s-w-u yeah
they probably want someone less like him
he didn't get arrested for like i was
gonna say it's like yeah they want him
but uh didn't he's like a rapist like
him without his behavior probably was he
the guy that got caught with all the
[ __ ] videos of the girls he was
[ __ ] with i think that's a korean
person yeah korean thing i'll tell you
this if if i if i was in trouble and he
came to save me i say go home [ __ ]
so if you're if you're if you're on the
[ __ ] boat that the pirates took over
and then the navy seals swinging
comes in
i'm here to moisturize your skin
what's your skincare routine my guy
what's your night cream
do you use toner first
he puts blush on before he fights the
pirates isn't this kind of how we feel
about robert pattinson as batman it's
kind of like he's not going to [ __ ]
hey this guy this guy i'd [ __ ] this guy
bro you [ __ ] this guy i [ __ ] this guy
and i watched the uh
trailer the pants in one i wasn't
convinced i know right because everyone
says watch the trailer and i watched him
like i don't know i don't know i feel
like in the trailer it looked like the
suit was too big on him that's what i
think like it looked like he was a
little what is it is it because pretty
boys remind us of kids like they're like
boys robin robert patton centered over
the [ __ ] can i see i gotta see a
reference he looks frail like chris woo
he looks frail
you know what i mean wait but what about
what about uh pattinson in the
lighthouse he's like much more rugged
than the lighthouse well he's like
creepy and [ __ ] though
and he's and he's next to willem dafoe
anybody looks good next to them
well default looks malnourished my guy
yeah this isn't the best shot can i see
the the funny one that everyone's like
man is not convincing me that's him but
you have to see the trailer really to
see him like he's like a skinny batman
he's a skinny batman but like his skin
tone just looks i don't
all i like to say is i like the i like
how they're representing what real men
look like you know instead of like this
[ __ ]
fake ass depiction of what men superhero
i mean they're sending us expectations
so high man we can't look like that
eight feet tall [ __ ] big ass chest
you know [ __ ] he just looks like elon
musk he looks like he got like a jaw
transfer he kind of looks like uh
remember from batman begins like the
scarecrow yeah silly silly and silly and
murphy he looks like silly and murphy
i'm with a young johnny depp right here
dude he's like a harry potter wizard to
me yes but he does who dies
he does look like a lot like in this
batman he battles the joker and anemia
if i was in the gang i wouldn't
[Laughter]
somebody give this guy a blood
iron
that would also be compelling you just
can't bleed because you're just bleeding
it's too long he gets all weak he's like
i gotta sit down bruh my blood won't
collapse give me an apple juice for me
he does look like low blood pressure as
a [ __ ] doesn't he that's a low
blood pressurization dude man blood
pressure we need to spike this somebody
give me a warther's toffee
yo where there's toffee though
let's go let's go apple looks like he's
going to collapse off of sprinting for
20 seconds dude his face looks cgi in
that though honestly why he looks so
hungry he looks like uh jake gyllenhaal
from night night stalker oh yeah
he does dude jake jones performance in
that though very good yeah jake
gyllenhaal looks hungry too
well that one in particular but he looks
he doesn't look that like skinny enough
in that movie he looked hella creepy he
was like definitely super gone jake
gyllenhaal would be a more believable
batman didn't he do didn't he do some
role where he got ripped though probably
yeah he was a boxer
southpaw
that was a good movie too i liked it
yeah he just looks too [ __ ]
under
malnourished yeah exactly that's
hemoglobin dudes with concave chests
they don't look like they could save
anybody yeah bro they look like they'll
pick a girl up and then they will
collapse christian bale was a dope ass
[ __ ] bat was good
he couldn't stop yelling at people one
of my favorite batman but because he
yells at people i'm like yeah that guy
could save my life but the yelling was a
little much i thought like the where are
the jigs
for me
it's the bad voice it was very but it
was a little much like keaton didn't
need that yep yeah i mean he let the
suit do the talk and kind of kind of
i don't think anybody liked the voice
change thing it's like you have all that
money you couldn't get a voice modulator
or something like which was sick about
the athletic one yeah he's like it made
sense you're a billionaire and he goes i
guess i can't afford it you know
like
hey guess what we've matched batman's
voice he's bruce wayne
the same guy same [ __ ] guy saying
jawline you should have went high
pitched instead of so low it would help
you
they should get a body language expert
like i think i think bruce wayne's
batman
he's moving around yo shout out to
violet that's true they have to say butt
[ __ ] too you know it's like you could
see that coming today i'm going to break
down ben shapiro
um so here he looks combative it's like
yeah that's ben shapiro
i saw a [ __ ] thing on my youtube
suggested that said ben shapiro reviews
dude i was like i've never been less
interested in a movie
reviewing uh pop culture music is the
funniest thing
oh when you did the uh the nicki minaj
song this is not music it's not the card
yeah no exactly that's the thing you
have to see ben shapiro you want to talk
about not being batman
hey what superhero could he play
[ __ ] robin dude he could be the
riddler oh he's going to say the riddler
he is the riddler huh
or the penguin maybe
if he got fatter yeah yeah i would like
to see him as bain scarecrow he could be
scarecrow oh yeah that'd be a good
scarecrow i'm sorry but dudes should not
play the violin this is [ __ ] up
this is [ __ ] up to me they're gonna
ruin violin
look at how he's looking at that violin
the video looks like he's gonna cry
there's a video of two asian violinists
roasting this flow about the violence
i've seen movies yeah i've seen it but
like he plays the violin the way that he
talks like super stiff like no emotion
for nerdy damn it's almost like he's not
you know paid as a violinist
he's a hell of a thing to point out
maybe he shouldn't be [ __ ] thinking
about how democrats are burning while
he's playing this song
i think you have more emotion behind
maybe they'll be more passionate yeah
he'd be like huh i love this i love this
song i've watched so many democratic or
like uh political debates it's hilarious
it's just crazy how
how uh for sure people are about things
that they aren't really involved in
they're the best it's very odd they go
this is how government you're not even
involved in government yeah so why are
you so sure about it yeah like how would
you know that's playing the game because
it's like that's like you have to like
believe it in order to debate it like
that strongly you have to believe it to
go vote for it too right because some of
these people bro they they go in the
voting booth and they they come out and
they get their sticker and they go on
social media and they're like i just
voted i did the greatest thing you could
do and they [ __ ] on you if you don't
yeah and then they open their mouth and
then politics shits in their mouth and
they're like thank you
they eat it up don't love it i just
don't understand and they did it olive
off memes
it's just kind of like how are you so
how is everybody so sure about
everything yeah like none of you have
doubt in your mind at all no like
everyone's crazy yeah
[Music]
you